dramatic all day long
hype another coating and a Renderman on
all your little tweets on Twitter Street
Road to see them update tweet tweet
tweet tweet
I'm really gonna treat
little follow we're officially yeah a
little tag in the big cloud tree the
wise old owl the big mr. tweets clapping
his tweets saying who you gonna tweet
tweet
I'm really good
my first plan ever
- do you understand
my powers for Twitter search who needs
Google anyway all day long doing nothing
else got Twitter on on pull your little
tweets on Twitter Street then I believe
in tweet tweet
don't talk to me and you'll be cool
you follow me I'll follow you back all
day long - Ana calling in a render it oh
boy your little tweets on Twitter Streep
love see the
I'm really good to me